[Musik]
die Nachrichten des Tages heute mit Jana
pareigis einen schönen guten Abend und
klar schauen wir heute im Sport noch mal
aufs nations League Spiel mit Norbert
Lehmann
und auf diese Themen blicken wir heute
ausführlich
muss die Ukraine mit Russland verhandeln
vor seiner erwarteten Reise Richtung
Kiew sagt Frankreichs Präsident macron
nur Gespräche könnten den Krieg beenden
ran an den Wind die Bundesregierung will
den Ausbau der Windkraft beschleunigen
und setzt die Länder unter Druck
auf der corona-welle in den Sommer die
Infektionszahlen steigen und der
Gesundheitsminister warnt vor der neuen
virusvariante
morgen wird auch Kanzler Scholz
voraussichtlich in die Ukraine reisen
das Land Gerät militärisch immer weiter
in Bedrängnis im Osten haben die
russischen Truppen bereits weitgehend
die Oberhand wie Deutschland und weitere
NATO-Staaten die Ukraine stärker
unterstützen wollen dazu gleich mehr
vorher schauen wir auf das
Kriegsgeschehen von Cisco von
thesenhausen
noch mehr als einem Monat erbitterter
Gefechte diese Luftaufnahmen
veröffentlicht die ukrainische Seite
heute es gibt in diesem Tagen kaum
Bilder aus der Stadt die russischen
Streitkräfte haben inzwischen
weitestgehend die Kontrolle die
ukrainischen Truppen haben sich in einem
Industriegebiet verschanzt ergeben
wollen sie sich trotz eines Ultimatums
bisher nicht auch 500 Zivilisten sollen
ukrainischen Behörden zufolge dort
ausharren die Eroberung der Stadt würde
der russischen Armee den Weg nach
slofensk und nach krematorsk der
Hauptstadt der Nachbarregion Don jetzt
eröffnen
durchhalten je mehr Verluste unser Feind
dort erleidet desto weniger Kraft wird
erhaben weiterzumachen der Donbass ist
entscheidend hier wird sich zeigen wer
in den kommenden Wochen die Oberhand
haben wird
der Ball betont Frankreichs Präsident
macron beim Besuch eines
nato-stützpunktes in Rumänien das kein
Weg an Gesprächen mit Russland
vorbeiführe um den Krieg zu beenden
wenn wir alles getan haben um den
Widerstand zu unterstützen und wenn wie
ich hoffe die Ukraine gewonnen haben
wird dann müssen wir verhandeln der
ukrainische Präsident und seine
Regierung werden mit Russland verhandeln
müssen und wir Europäer wir werden mit
am Tisch sitzen um über
Sicherheitsgarantien zu sprechen über
die Dinge die unseren Kontinent angehen
so sieht die Realität aus
mit dieser Botschaft reist macron weiter
erwartet wird dass er morgen mit
Bundeskanzler Scholz und dem
italienischen Regierungschef Draghi in
Kiew eintrifft
ja morgen sollen also offenbar Scholz
macron und Draghi in die Ukraine kommen
und vor Ort in Kiew ist für uns Johannes
Hanau Johannes wie sind denn die
Erwartungen der Ukraine an den
kanzlerbesuch
also Präsident der linski hat in den
vergangenen Tagen klar gemacht dass er
nicht davon ausgehe dass Scholz macron
und Draghi kommen also die
Regierungschefs der drei größten
EU-Staaten um die Hände zu schütteln
oder Fotos zu machen sondern das über
Substanzielles im Gepäck haben werden
und sein Berater einer der wichtigsten
Berater die hat gesagt man geht davon
aus wir haben das bestimmt gerade schon
gehört dass man die Ukraine auffordern
wird an den Verhandlungstisch
zurückzukehren das ist hier bislang
undenkbar das ist bislang keine Option
man vertraut Russland nicht man sei zu
oft belogen und betrogen worden das
einzige was die Ukrainerinnen und
Ukraine und auch den Präsidenten die
umstimmen kann wäre eine klare
Beitrittsperspektive zur Europäischen
Union und man geht davon aus dass es
hier so eine Art grunddeal geben kann
also wir setzen uns vielleicht an den
Verhandlungstisch wenn ihr uns dafür
garantiert dass wir schnell in die
Europäische Union aufgenommen werden
können und wenn ihr uns
Sicherheitsgarantien gibt dass ein
Ergebnis mit Russland dann auch zu einem
Frieden führt und der auch beibehalten
werden kann danke für diese Einschätzung
Johannes Hanau
und der ukraine-krieg ist auch das Thema
beim Treffen der Verteidigungsministerin
und Minister der NATO-Staaten und fast
20 weitere Partnerländer in Brüssel
dabei geht es vor allem um die
militärische Unterstützung für die
Ukraine Kiew bitte den Westen dringend
um weitere Waffen gerade bei Russland
neue Geländegewinne verzeichnet
für ein neuhahn in Brüssel die russische
Armee rückt ja immer weiter vor wie will
man die Ukraine da stärker unterstützen
wenn man will die militärische Hilfe
deutlich aufstocken das ist das zentrale
Ergebnis des Treffens heute Nachmittag
gerade eben hat die deutsche
Verteidigungsministerin Christine
Lambrecht hier bekannt gegeben dass
Deutschland drei sogenannte mehrfach
Raketenwerfer in die Ukraine liefern
will das ist modernes schweres Geschütz
mit einer Reichweite von immerhin 80
Kilometern die USA werden Lambrecht
zufolge 4 dieser Raketenwerfer in die
Ukraine liefern Großbritannien weitere
drei das ist einerseits eine neue
Qualität bisher hatte man ja vor allem
schweres Geschütz sowjetischer Bauart
geliefert jetzt also erstmals auch
moderne westliche Waffen schwere Waffen
andererseits aber muss man sagen es sind
eben nur in Anführungsstrichen 10 mit
mehrfach Raketenwerfer gewünscht hatte
sich die Ukraine Anfang der Woche 300
Stück davon man sieht also zwischen dem
Wunsch der Ukraine und der Wirklichkeit
westlicher Waffenlieferungen klafft
weiterhin eine ziemlich große Lücke
danke Florian neuhahn
und der Krieg der der fordert viele
Opfer aus der ukrainischen Führung heißt
es täglich würden 100 Menschen getötet
und 500 Menschen verletzt einige der
Verletzten werden nach Deutschland
gebracht und hier behandelt Dominik
Müller Russell hat ein ukrainischen
Soldaten an einer Klinik in Bochum
getroffen
er war zu Fuß unterwegs mit seiner
Einheit als ein russisches Geschoss ganz
in seiner Nähe einschlug erklärt der
21-Jährige Soldat Sascha seine
Kriegsverletzungen nun den Ärzten des ST
josef-Hospitals in Bochum eine
durchtrennte Schlagader und zerfetzte
Nerven
Ukraine ich habe starke Schmerzen
gespürt und deshalb wusste ich ich bin
verletzt aber nicht tot im Krankenhaus
in der Ukraine habe ich dann das
Bewusstsein verloren
die meisten Splitter sind raus nun
versuchen sie in Bochum die Nervenbahnen
wieder herzustellen sascha ist einer von
mir erst 300 Schwerverletzten Soldaten
und Zivilisten die die Luftwaffe von der
ukrainischen Grenze nach Deutschland
geflogen hat mit ihrer fliegenden
Intensivstation damit sich Ärzte
hierzulande um sie kümmern können in
Ruhe mit dem richtigen Equipment auch
wenn das nicht einfach ist
mit Kriegsverletzten haben wir in
Deutschland glücklicherweise nicht viel
zu tun deswegen ist das für viele
unserer Ärzte etwas Neuartiges es ist
schon allein der sprachliche Problem
viele der Patienten sind traumatisiert
und das zusammensprachliche Probleme
plus Traumatisierung ist eine
Herausforderung auch für Sascha den
Soldaten ist es in Bochum nicht leicht
zum ersten Mal hat er Zeit über alles
nachzudenken und ständig denke er an den
Krieg
du musst schon
niemand sollte Krieg erleben kein Mensch
auf dieser Welt es ist besser nicht zu
wissen was Krieg bedeutet ich wünsche
niemandem diese Erfahrungen zu machen
aber jeder in der Ukraine hat das jetzt
krieg es ist schwer
er will zurück und wieder kämpfen trotz
allem er ist Soldat sagt Sascha sein
Land braucht ihn
russland hat für morgen eine weitere
Drosselung der Gaslieferung durch die
Ostseepipeline Nord Stream 1 angekündigt
schon gestern hatte der Gazprom-Konzern
die durchleitungen deutlich reduziert
bei der Kürzung zusammen entsprechend
rund 60 Prozent der vorgesehenen
Tagesmenge als grundnet Moskau
Verzögerung bei Reparaturarbeiten der
Firma Siemens Energy ja das ist also die
offizielle russische Begründung Theo
call in Berlin wie ordnet die
Bundesregierung das drosseln der
Gaslieferung ein
nun für den Wirtschaftsminister ist es
schlicht eine vorgeschobene Begründung
und dabei wird er auch von der
Bundesnetzagentur übrigens unterstützt
die Verzögerung wegen Reparaturarbeiten
die könnten nicht für eine so
dramatische Verringerung immerhin 60
Prozent der Gasmenge verantwortlich sein
hinter den Kulissen hier in Berlin wird
man noch viel deutlicher es sei wohl ein
gezieltes Warnsignal vor der
kanzlerreise nach Kiew wissend wie
abhängig die deutsche Industrie von
russischem Gas ist und sei der Versuch
von Putin die Deutschen zu verunsichern
in dem über die Verknappung der Gaspreis
weiter hochgetrieben wird und damit
indirekt hier auch der politische Preis
für die Unterstützung der Ukraine noch
können die benötigten ersatzmengen am
Markt eingekauft werden aber natürlich
deutlich teurer und Robert Habeck
fürchtet dass der russische Gashahn
weiter zugedreht wird er sagte es fängt
vielleicht gerade erst an
Einschätzung von Theo Koll dankeschön
die Bundesregierung will die Windkraft
an Land schneller ausbauen das Kabinett
hat nun Pläne dafür gebilligt demnach
sollen bis 2032 rund 2% der jeweiligen
länderflächen für Windräder zur
Verfügung stehen einzig
Schleswig-Holstein hat diese Marke schon
jetzt erreicht gefolgt von Hessen
deutlich schlechter steht Bayern da
Schlusslichter bei den Flächenländern
sind Sachsen und Baden-Württemberg mit
0,2%. sollten die Länder ihr
flächenziell aber verfehlen könnten
Regeln zum Beispiel zumindestabstand
außer Kraft gesetzt werden eine
Stadtfeld berichtet
nur langsam geht er voran der Ausbau der
Windkraft vor allem in Bayern legen
strenge vom Land verordnete
Abstandsregeln zu Wohnhäusern viele
Projekte lahm nur mit großem Aufwand
einzelner Bürgermeister wie hier in
Flachslanden lassen sich Projekte
überhaupt realisieren
hier die Windräder die sie hinter mir
sehen die sind 800 bis 1400 Meter von
den Häusern weg damit kommen wir
wunderbar zurecht die Bevölkerung kennt
das jetzt seit sieben Jahren die wissen
dass das verträglich ist und die sind
akzeptiert häufig betragen die vom Land
vorgegebenen Abstände in Bayern bis zu
2000 Meter daher ist gerade mal 0,7% der
Landesfläche für Windparks ausgewiesen
viel zu wenig sagt
Bundeswirtschaftsminister Harbeck er
will Tempo beim Ausbau um die
Energiewende zu schaffen wer aber sagt
ich will Klimaschutz aber kein Ausbau
von der erneuerbaren Energien verlässt
jede Rationalität und Logik das ist also
die Geschäftsgrundlage dieser Regierung
sie handelt logisch und Ration
sein neues Wind an Landgesetz ist vom
Kabinett abgesegnet worden bis 2032
müssen danach die Bundesländer zwischen
1,8 und 2,2% ihrer Fläche ausweisen je
nach Wind Häufigkeit
habeex-gesetz sieht vor erreicht ein
Land seinen Ausbauzielen nicht fällt der
Mindestabstand Weg Politik mit der
Brechstange sagt Bayerns Bauminister
Bernreiter über die Abstandsregeln
müsste vor Ort entschieden werden wir
werden hier praktisch ausgehebelt und
die flächenzielle die werden hier
durchgedrückt die kommunale
Planungshoheit wird ausgehebelt und
darum sind wir eigentlich mit dieser
Vorgehensweise ganz und gar nicht
einverstanden in Flachslanden können die
Anwohner mit dem bisherigen Abstand zu
ihren Wohnhäusern leben aber noch mehr
Windräder wollen Sie hier auch nicht
im Streit um Zollvorschriften für
Nordirland hatte EU ein
Vertragsverletzungsverfahren gegen
Großbritannien eingeleitet Londons Pläne
die brexit Vereinbarung einseitig zu
ändern verstoßen nach Auffassung
Brüssels gegen internationales Recht die
britische Regierung hatte vorgestern ein
Gesetz auf den Weg gebracht
Zollkontrollen im Warenverkehr mit
Nordirland abzuschaffen
gestern Abend wollte Großbritannien
Asylsuchende mit einem Flugzeug nach
Ruanda abschieben doch der Europäische
Gerichtshof für Menschenrechte stoppte
die umstrittene Aktion in letzter Minute
die Maschine blieb am Boden einer der
sieben Betroffenen an Bord hat in
Straßburg Beschwerde eingereicht unter
anderem bezweifelt der Gerichtshof das
Ruanda ein sicherer Drittstaat ist
London will dennoch an dem Abkommen mit
dem afrikanischen Land festhalten
ein Thema gewinnt früher wieder an
Bedeutung als gedacht in Deutschland und
als erhofft und zwar Corona die
angekündigte sommerwelle ist leider
Realität geworden seit
Gesundheitsminister Lauterbach denn die
Zahlen steigen und steigen wenn in 24
Stunden kam mehr als 92.000
positivmeldungen hinzu die sieben Tage
Inzidenz beträgt 472,4 sie ist fast
doppelt so hoch wie vor einer Woche
112 weitere Menschen starben im
Zusammenhang mit dem Virus
tatsächlich dürfen die Infektionszahlen
noch höher sein denn sehr viele Menschen
lassen sich nicht mehr testen warum also
nun ausgerechnet im Sommer dieser
Anstieg ein Grund die leicht
übertragbare virusvariante ba5 breitet
sich auch in Deutschland aus und
Schutzmaßnahmen gibt es kaum noch mal in
Ihlow und Fabian Köhler wenn bei Sonne
vieles draußen läuft gehen die
corona-zahlen stark herunter so war es
zumindest die letzten Sommer nun zeigt
der Trend der Ansteckung nach oben Maske
tragen wäre eine erste einfache Maßnahme
um gegenzusteuern doch die meisten haben
sie längst dauerhaft abgelegt
Bundesgesundheitsminister Karl
Lauterbach warnt
die sommerwelle ist jetzt kein Grund zur
Panik sie muss uns auch nicht den Sommer
verderben aber es ist tatsächlich
wichtig dass wir etwas vorsichtiger sind
als sonst und dafür also muss jeder
selbst auch ein bisschen Sorgen dann
kann der Sommer gut werden Experten
sehen mehrere Gründe für den Anstieg der
Neuinfektionen der Wegfall der
allermeisten Schutzmaßnahmen und eine
neue subvariante von Omicron der 5 ist
tatsächlich ansteckender als vorherige
Varianten wir haben erhöhte Kontakte
jetzt natürlich im Sommer wir haben eine
sinkende Immunität durch die Tatsache
dass eben die Impfungen länger
zurückliegen und wir haben wenig
Maßnahmen die überhaupt die Ausbreitung
noch unterbinden können der
Gesundheitsminister empfahl zuletzt den
Risikogruppen sich eine vierte
corona-impfung verabreichen zu lassen
nun auch allen anderen diejenigen die an
etwas sei mal ruhigeren und
beschwerdefreien sondern haben wollen
sollten auch die Impfungen in Erwägung
ziehen denn die geschützt auch vor
Ansteckung zwar nicht perfekt aber gut
und sich schon sehr gut vor schweren
Verläufen die neue Variante ba5 soll
infektiöser sein aber im Verlauf nicht
schwerer wie derzeit Fälle in Portugal
zeigen
in Zeiten steigender Preise schauen
ArbeitnehmerInnen mit besonderem
Interesse auf Tarifverhandlungen in der
nordwestdeutschen Stahlindustrie gab es
jetzt eine Einigung ab 1 August erhalten
die rund 70.000 Beschäftigten 6,5% mehr
Lohn und Gehalt für die Monate Juni und
Juli gibt es eine Einmalzahlung von 500
Euro Auszubildender bekommt 200 Euro der
Abschluss gilt für 18 Monate
die CDU-Spitze hat sich auf einen
Kompromiss zur Frauenquote geeinigt so
hat Parteichef Merz die schrittweise
Einführung einer 50% Quote in der Partei
bis 2025 vorgeschlagen die Frauenquote
soll dann 2029 auf den Prüfstand
gestellt werden die Einigung muss noch
vom Parteitag im September beschlossen
werden ja und aus den Reihen der CDU kam
ja die bisher einzige Bundeskanzlerin
das Bundesverfassungsgericht hat Angela
Merkel jetzt gerügt weil sie sich in
ihrer Funktion als Kanzlerin negativ
über die AFD geäußert hatte und zwar
2020 zur ministerpräsidentenwahl in
Thüringen das habe die AFD in ihrem
Recht auf Chancengleichheit verletzt als
Kanzlerin hätte Merkel neutral bleiben
müssen die Einzelheiten von Birgit
Franke
die Wahl von Thomas Kemmerich mit den
Stimmen der FDP CDU aber auch AFD zum
Ministerpräsidenten Thüringens sorgt
nicht nur im Landtag für Empörung einen
Tag danach äußert sich die damalige
Bundeskanzlerin Merkel bei einer
Pressekonferenz mit dem südafrikanischen
Präsidenten dazu
da dies absehbar war muss man sagen dass
dieser Vorgang unverzeihlich ist und
deshalb auch das Ergebnis wieder
rückgängig gemacht werden muss wegen der
Äußerungen klagt die AFD vor dem
Bundesverfassungsgericht Merkel hätte
damals als Bundeskanzlerin nicht
einseitig Partei ergreifen dürfen
Karlsruhe gibt der AFD heute recht mit
dieser in amtlicher Funktion getätigten
Äußerung hat die damalige
Bundeskanzlerin die Antragstellerin in
ihrem Recht auf gleichberechtigte
Teilhabe am Prozess der politischen
Willensbildung verletzt
es sei nicht erkennbar so dass Gericht
das Merkel nur als CDU-Politikerin etwas
kommentieren wollte nur in dieser
Funktion hätte sie sich parteipolitisch
äußern dürfen die AFD zufrieden ich
denke es ist wichtig und richtig dass
hier immer wieder die Leitlinien und
auch die Grundsätze eingezogen werden
und dass die Regierung ja handelnden
Personen darauf auch aufmerksam gemacht
werden wie wichtig das Grundgesetz ist
und welche Eckpfeiler auch die
Neutralität hat
Politikerinnen und Politiker müssen
zukünftig noch deutlicher darauf
hinweisen ob sie als regierungs-
so und nun zum Sport zur nations League
Norbert siehste geht doch Deutschland
besieht die Teige mit 5:2 Fußballherz
was willst du mehr geht eigentlich nicht
der höchste Sieg
der höchste deutsche Sieg gegen den
Europameister seit dem 5:2 vor 83 Jahren
aber was jetzt 2022 wirklich zählt das
ist der Motivationsschub für Team und
Trainer jetzt fröhlich in den
Sommerurlaub und danach deutlich
entspannter in Richtung WM schauen
Hansi flieg erleichtert diesen Sieg
hatten er und sein Team bitter nötig all
das was bei uns vorgenommen haben haben
sie mich bravaroos gemacht das war ein
richtiger Stresstest auch für uns alle
der Stress wird umgesetzt in dominantes
Spiel gegen den stark umgebauten
Europameister Kimmich mit dem
Führungstreffer in der Folge weitere
Großchancen dann ein fauler an Jonas
Hofmann kurz vor der Pause Gündogan per
Elfmeter zum 2:0 Halbzeit stand die
Raumaufteilung war richtig gut wir jeder
wollte den Ball haben wir hatten richtig
gute Ball stattfinden nicht jeder
Abschluss gelingt gleich aber Nachsetzen
lohnt Müllers 3 zu 0 entscheidet das
Spiel bereits
ehe der zuletzt oft kritisierte Timo
Werner mit zwei Treffern etwas tun kann
fürs angeknackste Selbstbewusstsein die
Italiener mildern ihre Enttäuschung
durch zwei späte Treffer nur noch
ansatzweise dies tut der Freude der
deutschen Fans in Mönchengladbach jedoch
keinen Abbruch
und das letzte WM-Ticket für Katar geht
nach Costa Rica das dann auch deutscher
Gruppengegner sein wird im
Playoff-Finale gewann die
Mittelamerikaner schmeichelhaft gegen
das Spiel stärkere Team aus Neuseeland
mit 1:0 den entscheidenden Treffer
schoss Joel Campbell bereits in der
dritten Spielminute
zum Tennis beim WTA-Turnier in Berlin
ist Andrea Petkovic im Achtelfinale
ausgeschieden sie verlor gegen die
Belarus in aliexandras Novic mit 4:46 ja
und beim ATP-Turnier im westfälischen
Halle da hat das deutsche Spitzen Doppel
Kevin Krawitz und Andreas mies das
Viertelfinale erreicht die zweimaligen
French Open Sieger gewann im deutschen
Duell gegen Oscar Otto und Daniel
Altmaier im entscheidenden Match Teil
Break mit 10 zu 8 der Unterlegene
oskar-otte spielt übrigens als letzter
Deutscher Einzelspieler im Turnier im
Achtelfinale
und die Herren Einzel Halbfinals am
Samstag und das Finale am Sonntag zu
sehen bei uns im ZDF sehr schön Norbert
und jetzt weißt du was jetzt wird es
romantisch
hieß es der supermodus aufgegangen sieht
doch schön aus Gold orange über
Griechenland und Rot über Frankfurt am
Main je nach Lichtbrechung weltweit
dachten sich wohl beobachtende ich bin
so wild auf diesen erdbeermond
ungewöhnlich groß und hell schien unser
Himmlischer Begleiter denn er kam uns
ganz nah bis auf 360.000 km und so in
kosmischen Dimension ist das ja fast
schon eine zarte Berührung
und nun geht's nüchterner weiter aber
trotzdem interessant und zwar mit dem
Blick auf die Lottozahlen die
Gewinnzahlen lauten 11 21 29 30 44 47
und die Superzahl 0 weiter Gewinnzahlen
finden sie auf lotto.zdf.de und im
zdf-text auf Seite 557
und noch kurz zum Wetter morgen ist es
im Norden bewölkt sonst viel Sonne bei
20 bis 33 Grad am Wochenende wird es
noch heißer und ganz genau erfahren Sie
alles dazu von Christa Orban Marietta
Slomka hat um 21.45 das heute journal
für Sie tschüss
[Musik]
guten Abend hoch Mitteleuropas so heißt
die aktuelle Großwetterlage besagt es
hoch heißt Evrim liegt morgen über dem
Ärmelkanal zieht dann bis zum Samstag
nach Südosteuropa und damit wird der
Korridor frei für diese Hitze aus
Spanien heute Nacht können wir aber
erstmal noch durchatmen weil
Temperaturen zwischen 9 und 14 Grad nur
im Südwesten wird die Nacht lau bei 15
bis 18 Grad im Norden da verdichten sich
die Wolken heute Nacht noch mal über der
Mitte oft klar zu morgen hin ist dann an
den Alpen auch mal ein Schauer möglich
morgen tagsüber mischen sich da auch
immer wieder mal kräftige Gewitter mit
rein und zwar von den Alpen über den
Bayerischen Wald bis in das Zittauer
Gebirge die Wolken im Norden verschieben
sich im Tagesverlauf in den Nordosten
sonst sonnig und locker bewölkt bei
einem spürbaren Nordwestwind und wieder
dieses große Temperaturgefälle 20 bis 25
Grad im Norden ansonsten 26 bis 33 Grad
am Oberrhein und dann kommen wir zu dem
hitze-wochenende der Freitag sieht noch
ganz ähnlich aus wie der Donnerstag der
Samstag ist der Höhepunkt mit aktuell 38
Grad die möglich sind vor allem am
Oberrhein am Sonntag verlagert sich der
Schwerpunkt der Hitze dann in den Osten
des Landes dann kommen auch Gewitter und
von Nordwesten her wahrscheinlich wieder
eine Abkühlung guten Abend